Kristen how are you you look beautiful
thank you I'm well first of all I wore a
tie for you I've not been wearing a tie
but you know I adore you and I'm like
Kristen Chenoweth to me says real show
business and glamour so I put on a tie
for you hard to see I don't see I see
from here up so I don't see the whole oh
yeah yes yes what you want to change it
okay this is consist like you're hosting
an award show and you're and you're
doing outfit changes during on it no
one's done this yet no one's changed
outfits yet on a zoom interview this is
a first this is fantastic
it's very sensual to think of you
changing just off-camera I don't think
she can hear me of course you could hear
me and that was a creepy thing to say
wish I hadn't said it just you know just
the very idea of an attractive woman
stepping off camera saying I'm changing
is you know something that that's the
imagination running wild oh my god you
look fantastic
you want to go to lunch I know there's a
lot of adjusting up here what's
happening with ladies and gentlemen okay
I'm gonna try and settle down you're
talking to a very repressed Catholic boy
who's been in quarantine for seven weeks
so just let's take it easy you look
beautiful I love what you're wearing it
looks fantastic oh so much to talk about
first of all you know they always used
to say about James Brown hardest-working
man in show business I think you get
that title he has past you are
constantly on the go constantly in front
of crowds how are you handling this tour
as many artists were I you know I like
now I'm talking to my silverware by the
way I didn't even know I had a kitchen
so you did yes so I'm guessing your
whole life was you're on tour you're on
the road you're eating out you're eating
restaurant room service you're on the go
and then suddenly you're in a bus
station eating a sandwich out of a
vending
machine oh I hope you're getting paid by
the good people let's talk about the
captain yes what's a nice list me I
salute the captain even though he hurts
the roof of my mouth
I hear you like Captain Crunch with
crunch berries no I don't want to waste
my time and I don't need a berry in my
cereal whether it's a berry or not you
know it's not a very it's just like one
it's a bear